The best way to understand permutations and combinations
is by solving as many examples as possible.
In this example,
we have been asked to arrange the letters of the word rock.
In how many different ways,
can the letters of the word rock be arranged?
We have one word,
and we need to rearrange the letters to form different arrangements.
As rock has four letters, let's make four slots.
What exactly are we asked for?
In how many ways can the letters be arranged?
We can form arrangements like 'ORKC',
or 'CROK' or 'KORC' and so on.
How many such arrangements can we form?
If you have gone through our previous sessions,
you would Immediately realize that this problem is no different.
It's like we have been given four different digits,
and asked for the number of four digit numbers that can be formed.
Do we have any condition here? Nope!
We have simply been asked for the number of possible ways,
in which these letters can be rearranged.
So we can start from anywhere.
Say we start with the first slot.
In how many ways can the first slot be occupied?
The word 'rock' has four letters.
So the first slot can be filled with any of these four letters.
Four ways.
Now having filled the first slot,
in how many ways can the second slot be filled?
One of the letters has been used in the first slot.
Three remain.
The second slot can be filled in three ways.
If we have used an 'O' in the first slot,
then we can use any one from R, C and K for the second slot.
If we use a 'C' in the first slot,
then anyone from R, O and K can be used in a second.
Now having filled the first and the second slot with one letter each,
in how many ways can the third slot be filled?
Two ways as just two letters would remain.
And the fourth slot can be filled with just one way
as three letters have already been used up.
Four ways in which we can fill the first slot.
Three ways in which the second slot can be filled,
two ways in which the third slot can be filled
and after having filled these three,
only one way in which the last slot can be filled.
As we are filling the first and the second and the third and the fourth slot,
we multiply these four numbers to get the answer.
24 different ways,
in which the letters of the word 'rock' can be arranged.
And this is also four factorial.
You could have written this answer directly
provided you understood how we arrived at it.
The number of arrangements
or permutations of 'N' distinct objects is 'N' factorial.
Indirectly,
this question asked us for the number of anagrams of the word 'rock'.
And this includes all the meaningless ones as well!
Like 'OKRC', 'KROC' and so on.
So this was easy!
Now let me ask you a similar question.
How many different anagrams of 'mooc' can be formed?
'Mooc' stands for 'massive open online courses'.
How many anagrams like
'MOCO', 'COOM' can be formed using the letters of 'mooc'?
Try it out and we will see the solution in the next session.